go through this one video without saying
the word penis starting now penis hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to the seven second challenge
now this is a challenge that we have not
done in a long time but the app maybe
got updated I don't know what's new
November 25th 2015 fine you know what
we're gonna do it anyway because we
haven't done it in like here whoever
gets eliminated they're out Rock Paper
Scissors shoot well it's oh shoot yes
get up there alright name three things
you'd happily blow up with dynamite
okay house and a building the same thing
yeah that's pretty bad also like a house
in a car why are there dogs inside these
houses and like hey or Osama bin Laden
he said things if there's things human
beings are things invent a seven second
challenge that we do uh touching
touching my nose seven times whipping my
dick out in seven seconds you failed the
challenge so I created this social
network platform it's called fandom
where you're able to actually link and
look at all the information from funding
[Music]
I nailed that failed oh you fail that
failed they [ __ ] it name five things
you would not find in your mom's bedside
drawer a dildo a picture of my dad a
picture of my dead dog a computer and I
find your picture or and you wouldn't
find your mom's dildo in there somewhat
of a dick joke he already probably what
what did I break it
okay I'm owed some dodge balls yeah like
a scream Oh cat
name five things that shouldn't go on at
risk Christmas tree go a person a dog
car guitar and a Mexican's Hitler yeah I
mean I guess sing about what you had for
breakfast like a choirboy
that's actually true okay it's a wrong
thing combined two celebrities and give
it a dude Jessica Simpson and Britney
Spears Jessica Spears this is boring
Hitler Osama bin Laden Hitler bin Laden
there's celebrities yes everyone knows
and you go back to my original say five
things you would find under the seat go
under what the seed the seed or the CD
all right now give them another huh
explain what swimming is without saying
the word water it's where you do this
and move forward in a pool I got it I
heard it go off after I said pool I
still wouldn't know what you were
talking about it's where you go like
this and move forward in a pool so
you're just doing a lot of this in a
random location I swam in college name
three things that would ruin a first
date saying I love you did this happen
did you [ __ ] your pants
save your lover and then kills or have
been Farris do 20 one-handed class put
mark in a pen with cheese goat goats and
searching on Google on how to feed them
is that the show the boring show man
very good just kill us demonstrate a new
yoga move and give it a name
that's an actual yoga minute no it's not
it's called now watch this genius rap
your favorite Britney Spears
[Music]
threw me off cuz rap my favorite Britney
Spears ooh why wouldn't they just sing
it and same work go suggest three
alternative uses for bras okay you can
use them as a shovel you can use them as
two cereal bowls and you can use them
[Music]
where can I go there's nothing here I'm
blocked by his kursi [ __ ] never want to
exist go free Ethan peanut butter
no I name three things in your room that
begin with the letter T tarantula
introduce everyone to your invisible
unicorn and take it for a ride go hey
Ethan this is my unicorn unique hey Mark
this is my unicorn unique hey Catherine
this is my unicorn unique I was writing
a name and do impressions of three TV
characters go ah
Squidward thanks her from dense textures
lab because they leave with a
requirement yes [ __ ] act like a
ballerina who's broken her ankles lose
three words to describe what you were
like in 2010 go tall dark and handsome
you know dark dark
I was I was tan in 2010 I worked as a
lifeguard hi guys okay I'll give it to
him say something creepy related to
serial I'm not wait you said it was kind
of creepy but what you said wasn't
pretty you wouldn't be creeped out if
you walked into a room and you saw a
dude staring at cereal and said I'm
gonna put you right in my [ __ ] I want
to be creeped out I'd be concerned
that's the wrong man are you okay
invent a pizza with three disgusting
toppings pizza with blood semen and poop
it's makeup a course for a country in
Western song my dog sound like a course
that sounds like I could sing along to
that that was totes happen chorus that's
not a course it's like in last night oh
do do do do do I
I'm full moon so at the end um your dead
brother responds really killed by Bowser
that's a horrible life it feels like
eviscerated and cut open is like but
then he's like it's okay you're gonna
come back we're gonna end on a good note
we should make our own this is [ __ ]
we know what funny is we know what
hilarious miss can you make up your own
tongue twister Sally sac de satchel and
suck the son of a [ __ ] sign that sex
was sweet
typical yeah
reenact the typical day of Tyler I'm
better than everyone here I can move
this couch I've got the strongest muscle
they called me hogs ooze and he-man in
high school I've only got half a face
that's a baby half a face that's a man
smile the average game plays who's that
I'm ready I have acne and my channels
dying [ __ ] gold I'll never be as
successful you go I'm just copying you
and dragging every [ __ ] way oh no
alright okay I'm gonna do it I'll get it
so much nothing I've gots I'm so still
no I've got this copier let's move away
and crush my dreams yeah yeah I'm a
slave I could do so I can't end up with
meanness
I can't mean my gone Oh million
subscribers yes a diamond play button ah
there's got to be one drop of comedy
somewhere to the end that's the end of
the video thank you everybody so much
for watching and thank even's in the
description
Tyler's Twitter is also in the
description hope thank you let me know
what you thought of it down in the
comments below thanks again everybody
for watching we're never gonna do this
again
as always I'll see you in the next video
bye bye
welcome to crying game plays crazy I'm
Tyler Huff glue I have an inflation
fetish
I'm Tyler I'm Tyler
I got severe hemorrhoids I want fish an
entire family adults I'm Tyler I'm
Charlie I've got new legs